Nick Smith the Toronto Star you talked
earlier before the game of both Kyle and
his foul trouble and trying to avoid it
tonight you think it and the other guys
issues just cause some flow problems
free for your rotation a little bit I
just think we had a you know a few guys
in foul trouble kind of early and and
first half and then you know third
quarter as well and then fourth quarter
so I don't know we were we were we got
it you know you got a play physical
basketball but you gotta be able to
adjust and all those kind of things and
try to try to stay out and then you got
to avoid the silly ones too you know
that's all I got
do you see Kyle sometimes maybe getting
some silly ones because he's a little
over-aggressive well I got I got a look
at him right I know one you know he's
he's a great charge taker right and I
know one of them was possibly a charge
block charge you know and those are
tough they go each way but maybe that
sixth one I didn't really see it in the
game so you know in the backcourt you
know probably 80 feet or so from the
basket those are those are those are
ones you gotta be careful know
especially when you got five but I'll
need to look at that first Tim back
right Nick Tim Reynolds with the AP back
other side okay know when the next two
and a half days before you guys get back
out there how much you're gonna be
thinking about the first six minutes of
the half and and how that just was
obviously very uncharacteristic for the
way you guys have been playing for the
last couple months yeah I mean I'm
certainly gonna have to look at it and
you know I've always said even this
series in the last series that offense
is really important taking care of the
ball and score in it because if you
don't they're coming at you really fast
the other way and again we've got to be
able to get our defense set up and it's
a lot harder when you're not taking care
of it or scoring just kind of playing it
back through my head I thought we had I
know we had one little turnover where
Danny slipped to the rim and and tried
to kick it out and and but I think you
know Mark had a couple real nice little
looks there and and we had four or five
decent possessions there and we just
came away empty on all of them and then
we had probably four or five that were
not good
possessions either so you know certainly
the offense hurt the chance to get the
defense set up there so yeah I'm gonna
have to rewatch that I'm probably not
gonna enjoy that very much but I'm not -
check it out
right here in the second row Mikaela
great TSN you guys got a little bit of
life there from Fred vanvleet for a
moment I'm just wondering what you saw
from him in the minutes that you got
from him yeah he put a lot where do you
play tonight almost 40 yeah he was he
was good
obviously he's working really hard on
defense to you know garden curry he was
running the team he was he was making
really quick decisions off the
pick-and-roll you know he had a he had
some good looks probably probably hadn't
played that many straight minutes in a
while I think he had a couple that are
late he's probably a little tired but he
you know he kept taking him and stepping
into him but you know 17 points from him
is great and running the team the way -
it's great coach Peter innopolis Oh
Marty has television your team has
really moved the ball effectively the
last couple of games coming from the
Milwaukee series tonight 17 assists on
35 made field goals
what did Golden State do differently
tonight defensively well they were
obviously a little more aggressive and
up in us a little bit but again I think
we've got - I thought we were just a
little bit impatient and not didn't hold
enough composure just either a get to a
strong shot or B move it to the next one
you know I thought we hit an action and
something would be there and they'd
cover it up with some help defense well
when when there's help there's got to be
somebody else probably open on the other
side of the floor and I thought we kind
of shot a few too many into multiple
defenders or two defenders around the
basket where those probably should have
been maybe swung to the other side again
I got I got a look at it a little bit
but I just felt like we were a little
quick when there was something else
maybe maybe just a little bit better
open Michael here Nick Michael Grange
from Sports Net sort of on the flip side
of that you look at their assist totals
really like 34 on 38 or something and it
seemed they were able DeMarcus
especially was able to find guys on some
back cuts and there's a lot of stuff in
the dunker spot looking open is that
just a function just you know
pick a poison and trying to stay out
them at 3:00 and they're gonna have
space to use yeah I mean you know
obviously you got to get up on those
guys flying off the screens you know
curry and Thompson and they did a really
good job of getting out of there with
speed tonight those guys getting
downhill you know and again a lot of
those were just probably mistakes by us
right weak side mistakes or or just a
half step too slow
the other night we got away with a few
of those where we were a half step too
slow but we would kind of somehow
recover out of them tonight they were
really getting downhill quickly they
took it off the dribble a lot better too
you know it just wasn't a second half
especially just wasn't nearly as
physical of game as we've seen in the
playoffs it was just it was just hard to
to move and body a little bit tonight
and it caught up with us a little bit in
the second half towards the center coach
Luis Atzmon Raptors Republic those last
5-6 minutes there wasn't a lot of
scoring what were you thinking how are
you feeling down that stretch well I was
feeling really good because we stopped
their scoring right and finally finally
got something figured out there to slow
him down and we were getting a bunch of
wide open shots I think we missed three
wide-open threes in a row there to cut
it to maybe four right and maybe it was
five I don't I don't know what exactly
what it was but a bunch of bunch of
stops in a row and we didn't didn't get
much to show for it at the other end but
I you know really proud of our guys for
fighting and battling the ball was not
bouncing our way at all right I mean
even on the last play Kleier just got
three incredible offensive rebounds in a
row they almost threw it right to him on
that one and that got through his hands
somehow and then they end up kicking out
for that three which you know we're
probably gonna probably gonna live with
that there cuz if he misses that we get
a rebound to tie or win the game right
here in the front Nick Melia Hernandez
at the London with the series tied going
into Oakland and no longer being on home
court what are the prominent focal
points that you're going to bring over
to the next
both games yeah I mean we're in the same
boat they're kind of we're in coming
here you know we got to go out there and
get one right that's all we got to do is
get one and we can do that we're gonna
go read and mark here last two questions
Anika read for grave with CBSsports you
guys half court defense has been
dominant this entire playoffs it wasn't
as dominant tonight there were kind of
some holes here and there what did you
think was one of the one missing element
specifically in the half court yeah I
mean first of all our half court
defenses first of all it's about getting
it set up right there was a lot of quick
possessions by them again probably due
to our offense so that's the first thing
second thing on half court offense is
very physical and it wasn't very
physical tonight mark lies right in the
right way and then again we just made
some weak side mistakes sorry
mark last question here nick mark
schwartz ESPN i'm wondering if you could
take me through the final possession
especially the fact that Iguodala shot
it with about five seconds left on the
clock and the fact that he was so wide
open during that possession yeah I think
um you know we scored the basket and I
look up and there's 26.4 or something
left
that's a definite foul situation right
you just they can hold it all the way to
the end throw it up there hit the rim
and the horns gonna go off I've been in
that situation before so usually usually
under 28 if there's 28 or more you're
gonna play solid defense if it's 27.9 or
under you're not we're trying to trying
to file we had a couple chances there on
on draymond I think Livingston and then
back to dream on and then curry got it
and we didn't want to file but we put a
good blitz on him we almost made him
throw it away and I think if they're
gonna take a shot and give you a chance
there I'm gonna probably live with the
one that ended up being taken that's
gonna probably roll I'm a probably roll
with that probably we should have filed
before that but he like I said he misses
that we called timeout we go down with a
chance to win the ballgame
unbelievably somehow
Steph said after the game to Doris Burke
that he thought it was in his words
disrespectful to leave a player like
Iguodala that wide open what did what
did you think of that well we weren't
disrespecting anybody we were up
guarding hard and we put two on stuff
and we held through it almost threw it
right to Kauai right pretty good defense
you know they were scrambling around
running around like crazy but then they
found a key right they found him and
like I said I'm if he's gonna if he's
gonna take that and give us a chance to
get the ball back and win the game I'm
gonna probably live with that it wasn't
like we were disrespecting him and not
not trying to guard him we were in a
trap and rotating out of there and and
again I'd like to go back and try that
again about ten times and see if one of
them doesn't go our way Thank You coach
all right thanks